Ai. I know we just met, but
will you marry me? Yes sir.
Roger.
Hello world.
It's Sir Raj and Uber released a tool a
few weeks ago called Ludvig calling it a
code free deep learning toolbox
and that brings up the question,
can you really use AI if
you don't know how to code,
the answer is definitively
Bush's is Omar wizzle.
I'll explain how lewd vig works as well
as give a brief demo of using it to
create a chat Bot without coding.
Also use this opportunity to recommend
some other code free machine learning
tools afterwards. So smash that
like button and let's get started.
The amount of interest in AI technology
over the past decade keeps on
increasing.
Every company is becoming a tech company
and Marc Andreessen's famous quote,
software is eating.
The world has come to fruition no matter
what field you work in from agriculture
to finance to Penguin Ology,
you're going to be dealing with
data in some way, shape or form.
If you have any kind of website or APP,
you'll be generating data
from it and even if you don't,
you can still learn from data.
Basketball players can use data analytics
tools on replay videos to analyze what
their ideal position should be
or how to improve their form.
Teachers in public schools can use their
student's submission data to provide a
more personalized learning
experience for each student.
Boosting assessment scores musicians can
create sounds more optimized for their
audiences.
Preferences like auto,
auto autotune and people
of all professions can use
data to optimize how much
time they spent on certain
tasks like sleeping, eating,
running and meditating so that they
can improve their health and wellbeing.
But reading data directly,
row by row, column by column,
sorting through PDFs and
images and videos and comments.
This is cumbersome and slow and as that
data grows in size, it's near impossible.
That's where AI comes in. Ai Is a
collection of mathematical techniques.
Many of them,
decades old.
In the past you needed a phd to have
access to the learning materials necessary
to understand AI,
but with the internet came an absolute
explosion in the number of available
courses and tutorials to help
explain how this technology works.
The four pillars of Ai are education,
computation, data and algorithms.
You've got access to data sets made
publicly available across the web.
Access to computing resources on sites
like Google, Colab and Kaggle kernels,
educational resources like my
channel, hit subscribe. By the way,
I'm going to continue to create relevant
educational videos here every single
week. I live to serve my youtube
audience and of course the algorithms,
many of which have been open
sourced as code repositories.
There are lots of different AI
algorithms and they require knowledge of
different mathematical disciplines
like linear Algebra, calculus,
probability,
theory and statistics.
Generally developers use tools like the
c plus plus programming language and red
bull to write out these
mathematical techniques like
support vector machines and
decision trees so they could apply
them to data to retrieve insights.
But C plus plus is a nontrivial
language to learn and while powerful,
it's quite verbose, requiring many
lines of code to achieve a certain task.
Nowadays,
Python has become the most popular tool
to use machine learning models because
it's readable and has a small learning
curve and a python library called care.
Os has been the de facto easiest way
to use python to build machine learning
models in just a few lines of code,
but yet this still requires
code and not only that,
it requires some knowledge of the ideal
hyper parameter values to use and what
type of model to use in the first place.
Can we make AI a tool that doesn't even
require programming knowledge to use?
Uber's Ludvig is a step in that direction.
Ludvig has been used internally by Uber
for two years and they just open sourced
it to get more contributions
from the data science community.
Ludvig is in fact a python library,
but their code free claim comes from
the fact that you don't actually have to
write any code to use it.
All you need to do is input some
commands into a command line,
which I'll show you how to do in your
web browser easily using Google's colab
environment to create a chat Bot.
Lewd Vic has two main functions,
training models and using
them to make predictions.
We can go to colab.research.google.com
to boot up an AI training environment in
the cloud.
Once we select Gpu as our runtime type,
we can install Ludvig by copying and
pasting the insulation commands directly
from the lewd vague get hub repository.
Don't hate copy paste.
Once it's done installing,
we can find a movie dialogue Dataset
as a CSV file and download it.
This is a movie dialogue Dataset that
contains 220 k conversations between 10 k
pairs of movie characters.
This data set has two columns which
contained conversational elements.
The first column is a
collection of statements,
questions and responses from one person.
The second column is a collection of
responses to the first columns, texts.
We're going to use Ludvig to learn from
this data set so that our chat Bot knows
how to respond to us.
We can upload our CSV file directly to
Colab and once it's there we need to do
one more thing before training the
model and that's defining the model
definition file,
which will copy and paste from Lewd
Vic's example in the user guide.
I'll explain this in a second.
Now we can train our model using the
command Ludvig experiments and two flags,
one that asks for the name of the Dataset
and the second which asks for the name
of the model definition file we just
created. That's it. It's training.
We didn't have to code out a model
nor set any hyper parameters.
It's already training.
It automatically performs a random split
of the data into different training,
validation and testing sets.
Preprocessing processes them so they
ready for training and build models with
preset hyper parameters.
It trains the model until the accuracy
on devalidation sets stops improving or
the maximum training time
is reached before you tattoo
the Lewd Vig logo to your
forearm.
Check this out.
We can also visualize how the model
improves over time by using the visualized
command to test the model. We can run the
predict function and given some input,
a conversational sentence.
In our case,
it will give us an output using
the trained model. It's response.
Now we can download and use the train
weights file for a mobile APP or web app
to offer people a Chat Bot. That's all
it takes to train and test the model.
Ludvig has examples in their documentation
for many different types of scenarios
we'd want to use AI for in
areas like sentiment analysis,
image classification, time series,
forecasting and text classification.
Even image captioning,
which is non trivial to train.
So let's take a step back behind
the curtain to see how it does this.
Dilute vig python repository contains
a series of deep learning models,
all sorts of neural networks,
convolutional recurrent, et cetera.
The way they architect each pipeline for
every training process is by using the
idea of data type specific
incoders and decoders.
The idea is that incoders we'll map raw
data, whatever we input text videos,
images into tensors,
which are multidimensional
arrays of numbers than decoders.
We'll map these 10 servers to outputs,
which are the predictions.
It also uses the concept of a combiner,
which combines the tensors from all
the input incoders processes them and
returns a tensors to be used
for the output decoders.
So each of the different data types
we have as features in our Dataset,
whether they are numerical or binary has
its own encoder. And this is flexible.
It can use different models
for the encoder and a decoder.
The way it knows the characteristics of
the data in which encoder to use is by a
small input from the data scientist.
That input is the model definition file.
It specifies the input and
output features of the model.
It helps Ludovic understand what are
we trying to predict and using which
features of our data and since
Ludvig is a python library,
it does have a programmatic API.
If you do want to use python,
which looks pretty simple, load the
Yammel file, train the model and test it.
It also allows developers to create their
own encoders and decoders to use for
further experimentation.
More of the focus of a data scientist
will be on fine tuning the architecture of
the target model rather than
repetitive training work.
The Yammel file can be as detailed
or as high level as we'd like.
We can specify certain hyper
parameters or use the default ones.
The whole point of this is a drastically
shorten the experimentation cycles in
deep learning applications.
So Luke Vig is one great step in the
direction of getting to a point where
everyone gets to use AI technology,
but as you can see it does still require
knowledge of Unix commands and flags.
Another great tool is admittedly
Microsoft's Azure machine learning studio.
It's a browser based visual drag and
drop environment where no coding is
necessary.
The idea is to let anyone go from idea
to deployment in a matter of clicks.
I actually already have a video on that
link will be in the video description.
A zero has been around for a
few years now. It works well,
but it's still not extremely
simple to use. In fact,
drag and drop as an interface for
machine learning isn't a new idea.
In 92 accompany introduced a drag
and drop tool for advanced analytics.
That's 26 years ago. Why
isn't everyone using AI? Then?
The answer is that users still need to
know what to drag and where to drop it.
Some of these tools have hundreds of
mathematical operators in the form of
blocks to deal with,
which requires training to understand
and it's still relatively complex for
beginners.
Experts can easily use these tools,
but experts don't want drag and drop.
If they understand the math,
they just want to code.
It's easier to debug.
So there is an excellent opportunity
here to create a web service that uses a
freemium model and allows
absolute beginners,
meaning people who don't know how
to code the ability to train models.
All they would need to do is drag
and drop their data. That's it.
Automate the process of building
complex data, preprocessing pipelines,
hyper parameters, model
selection, everything.
This is all already possible.
There are barriers,
hyper parameter search strategies like
Basie and optimization and grid search
that enables this capability and
there's even a proprietary solution for
enterprises called data robot
that does this pretty well.
The con is that it's an enterprise
price point that check it out though if
you've got the budget for it.
Another cool startup that has claimed
that they are working on this is Loeb.
Their demo videos look pretty magical.
It's a glimpse into the future of Ai.
They were acquired by Microsoft and
still haven't released our product to the
general public,
so we'll have to wait on that.
It's a drag and drop interface
that seems to marry ease of use and
configurability pretty well. Also,
shout out to deep cognition.ai.
It's both the visual editor and code ide.
You can drag and drop blocks and it
creates code alongside it, which is sick.
There are three things to remember
from this video. Uber's lewd.
Vague is a python library that lets
anyone use deep learning by issuing a few
unix commands, no code necessary.
It uses a flexible data types,
specific encoder,
decoder model that has default settings
but can also be fine tuned by the user
and other code free options include
Microsoft as your data robot. Indeed,
cognition. What's your favorite
tool to use for data analytics?
Let me know in the comments section and
please subscribe for more programming
videos. For now, I'm going to learn
some advanced math, so thanks a lot.